Năm 1 nhìn chăm 2, 3 đại hội là thứ 3 hội nhà bảo việt nắm.
Chủ tiết khô chí mấy người dài nhìn mạnh, nhận vụ của bảo chí là phục vụ nền dân phục vụ cạnh mạnh.
Thực hiện lời dài của người, lớn lốt nhà bảo đều nỗ lực thực hiện lốt nhìn vụ nân
cao bản lính và đạo lúc nhìn nhật.
Một trong năm qua, thực lượng những người là bảo cạnh mạnh luôn, giữ vướng sử mạnh là cạnh kai nối dài của đàn và nhé nước.
Chuyện mặt chạy thông tin, là tìm nói chung thực vụ nền dân.
Tuy nhiên là điều xấu sắc nhất và thiêu lym nhất trong kê chuyển thống vẻ bán của hội bảo việt nắm trong bệ thập kỳ qua.
Chính là tinh tình tin phong, tinh tình cũng hình của những người là bảo vệ nạ.
Thông các cuộc khăn chiến trước đây, cùng là thông công cuộc kỳ sây dừng bảo vệ tục quốc biệt thả mẹm này.
Thì chúng ta thấy những người là bảo luôn luôn ở chính trứng đầu của những giúp vụ kết mạnh.
Quân trọng nhất, nắm bảo vệ tinh tình.
Bột chân năm qua bao chiến tinh mạng Việt Nam đã thịt được phai trò và xu mạnh của mình trên mọi mặt chất dừng ngoài giáo phòng trúng thầng nhúng.
Vó phần sây dừng và bảo vệ tục quốc và đứa hình a Việt Nam ra thế giới.
Các nhà báo là chiến dí với ngồi bút, chỉ thệ xóc mén là chiến tài, chủ chương đe yếu ngồi hẳng,
chính xác phóc lật của nhà nước, tới công chúng một cách chi sắc, tìm thầy bài yếu qua.
Trong thời gian về qua, bảo chí kết mạng Việt Nam đã và đang làm dứt tốt mai trò này.
Tôi thật sự cảm phục, mề chỉ tìm thật làm việc của các nhà báo của nên bảo chí kết mạng Việt Nam chúng ta trong mối tắc phần đều thể hiện liêm tiến với đàn.
Với nhà nước, sử xay mới ngàn nhập.
Nhưng trên nghe thật vọc công dân, sây dừng đất nước, phung trự nhiên dần.
Chúng kính mề công me so, bảo chí kết năng đăng truyền mình mạng, tư bảo ín truyền thông,
đến bảo địa tự, bốt các, lai Xuím, chỉ tự nhiên tạo hỗ trợ sản xuất độ dùng,
tất cả đàn được áp dụ nhạm đáp ở lúc cao khai gạng đa dạng của công chúng về đại.
Đơn cử, bảo như dân trong gì kính nhạm nằm mề nằm giải phòng mình nằm thông nhất,
đá tổ chức một cuộc trên là tự các, tức hợp cùng ở phòng đặc biệt sử dụng công nhạm
tự tế hào các gương, giúp người xem đặc biệt là dưới chay, dễ tiếp trả lịch sử.
Em thấy là có mềm mối này nó, các là dễ tiếp trảm bối, dễ vợ bế dưới sợ,
Bai tự là tổ chức khó này, rồi nhìn thấy c glove nốt hết lại rất cả đánh đảo đ khi xử dụng,
rất là chỉ kết nặng.
Bởi vì mình kế tự , trặc tự nhiên sử dụng,
nó sẽ kìa lưới thôn và thúng gái này không?
Bây giờ trị dịch rất đà sound, cũng có các video của các video ở bên bên bên bên bên bên bên bên bên bên bên bên bên.
Lý gó đảm c glove trị là các bạn chế, nó Rush thôi.
Để biết được, chỉ là mắt người tương nhau, để phần nha to trả ngon tụi người mới để biết đâu, ngay lịch sử như nào.
Tụi mới và sáng tạo không chỉ là yêu câu mà đã trở thành xức sống, hành phản lữ nghề ghê phụm người là hôm nay,
đương đề tương lai, nên báo chi tức mạo Việt Nam đã phục tiêu xây dựng đủ người là hảo trình nghiệp,
hiện đại, nhưng đồng thời cũng nhên văn, chắc nghiệp và gặp bỏ với nhân dân.
Chó mùi sáng hồi phát triển nháng, sự thật vẫn luôn là giả trị có lỗi và báo chi tức mạo bằng sự đồ mới không ngừng,
sẽ tất cả gặp tình nói tình gây là cầu mỗi chúng thật dựng đà, và đơn dân.